and you guys were on the road with
gym class heroes fall out boy and little
wayne was that the tour no that wasn't
the tour
but us being on tour with fall out boy
and gym class heroes
that's a hell of a tour back then it led
to the
being in the same places as well right
right right right lil wayne
mtv vma right it was supposed to be fall
out boy
uh lil wayne and like i think it was a
t-pain or somebody was supposed to
perform sounds about right for that for
that
yeah but i don't think t-pain could
could perform because he was in the
suite at the palms with
kanye doing that other song good life
yeah they was doing that song
so they was like damn we needed somebody
else to fill in t painting or kanye spot
i think for the song it was
so it was just like yo tiger go to show
moment and that's how they get
wow they really did that song too it was
dope it's called arms race i still
remember it like it was just i remember
that song yeah it was crazy man like
those was the days that made me feel
like
you're really soaking up and learning
man so that's why everything to come my
way i be feeling so well prepared like
even sitting right here with you i'm
just so well prepared
you know what i mean like yeah it's
crazy because being around like uh you
know
fallout boy at that time is the biggest
band gym class hero's probably the
hottest band oh yeah for sure
uh i still talk to travis man yeah you
got a new song too called spoon full of
cinnamon he's a [ __ ] legend yeah
legend dude if it wasn't for him i
wouldn't have my lip pierced i wouldn't
you know they had a song called that's
the way i dressed they had a song called
pillmatic
uh oh i love that yeah man
jim class heroes had some [ __ ] before
they popped my favorite song was
viva the white girl yeah yes now gym
class heroes had some [ __ ] but
it's crazy because you obviously coming
from south central and then
kind of cutting your teeth in in the
game like around like
the other side of the music biz not that
not necessarily the rap [ __ ] but kind of
being on the road seeing
what it's like to you know it made me
realize and i learned that
all your money comes from torrent
because
you got to break so much down with the
label the manager to break even
your crew and all that but when you're
on tour that's when you really eat you
know i mean you could go out there
get a real bag you could push your merch
and stuff and you know people might take
a percentage of that but when you tour a
lot that's where a lot of your money
come from so
when i learned that i'm like man i love
being on the road because it would be
dates where
i mean it'll be tourists where people
are on the road for like four or five
months they don't do that no more
no no not no more they don't drop no
album be on the road for four or five
months so
it made me appreciate that